this morning we're getting an inside
look at a new book that aims to help
people struggling with mental health it
Blends the advice of experts with real
stories from real people across the
country one in five adults in the U.S
experiences mental illness according to
the advocacy group the National Alliance
of mental health ornami and one in 20
adults experiences serious mental
illness You Are Not Alone the Nami guide
to navigating mental health is by Dr Ken
Duckworth nami's chief medical officer
he spoke with about 130 people about
their mental health Journeys for the
book and he joins us now good morning
um you said that you wrote this book
because it was a book you needed growing
up
Michelle my dad had very bad bipolar
disorder and was a wonderful human being
playful loving charismatic but my family
couldn't talk about it I became a
psychiatrist that's how far I took this
problem to make sense of it I wasn't
like the science whiz or you know
anything like that I did it because I
was I loved him and I wanted to know how
could I help him fortunately I found
Nami over time which is a whole group of
people who want to help each other and
teach each other so this was the book
that I needed a practical book I wanted
to learn from real people
how did you manage your mental health
condition how did your family learn to
talk to each other about it because my
family never quite figured that out so
that's the Genesis of this book I became
a psychiatrist and I still didn't see
this book you talked to uh I think it's
130 people over several dozen different
states what kind of takeaways did you
hear from how those families dealt with
mental illness in their midst
there's a lot of wisdom in people who've
lived with things that we have not
tapped everybody knows there's a mental
health crisis and everybody knows
there's not enough mental health
professionals well it takes eight years
to make a social worker why don't we
learn from people who are living with
these conditions they have developed
wisdom in their families and in their
own experience it was a beautiful
experience I wish you all could have sat
through these Zoom calls with people all
across the country from 38 States they
share what did they take away from their
mental health experience everybody wants
to talk about Solutions and you know one
solution is to find someone you can work
with talk to go to a professional but
there's one solution involving paper
plates which I love which actually is
the solution for me in my life could you
tell that story it's a woman named
Catherine who I Came Upon she's from
Rhode Island and she discussed going to
a peer support meeting other people with
mental health conditions and she says my
life is overwhelming I have young
children and I can't manage my life I
can't manage it and she said a woman in
my group said something to me that I'd
never occurred to me two words that
changed my life paper plates and she
said paper plates made the difference
between me being able to raise my family
while living with a mental health
condition I couldn't run a kitchen and
you'd give up on the kitchen and you
love your kids right so Catherine's
story is one of the many Beautiful
Stories
that's so true definitely true in my
household yeah the heck with the
dishwasher yeah let's look at my
language right now you mentioned how
growing up your family didn't talk about
me yes and I believe that is a large
majority of this country and around the
world
what do you say to those people who
don't necessarily have the words to
approach someone that's in their family
someone that they love and it's just a
dark cloud hanging over them I asked
some of America's best research experts
to complement these lived experience
experts that we just talked about the
paper plates woman it's a lived
experience I asked the man who invented
motivational interviewing this is a
strategy of how to talk to someone
without saying Nate I think you need
help and then you say no Ken I don't end
of conversation the idea is I listen
very carefully for what you are actually
worried about Nate and then I try to
come alongside and support you right
he's one of the 35 experts in the back
of the book answering common questions
that I get which is how do I talk to
somebody in my family who doesn't want
help and that's one of the questions
that I get asked and so you know culture
is so important I just happen to see
Death of a Salesman last night and for
the first time this new rendering gave
me an understanding what this play was
really about and so culture has a lot to
do with how it sort of you know frames
this message how would you tell people
or how what does it look like beyond
that on the culture piece I interviewed
people who self-identified they told me
who they were different 11 different
races and ethnicities and what you find
is there's a lot of commonality a woman
who grows up in Japan is told we suck it
up the next day I interviewed a woman
who grew up in Austria and she told we
were told never to speak about this and
I thought the Japanese culture and the
Austrian culture wouldn't appear to be
similar right but apparently on the
mental health Dimension many cultures
have come to the conclusion that
something that is common all right and
costs lives out of sight out of
mindfulness a lot of sight out of mind
isolation kills people in the mental
health and addiction space this book is
designed to find people just like you
important for us to talk about and bring
it out into the open Dr Ken Duckworth we
thank you thank you thank you you are
not alone as available today